اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم
مشاهدينا ومتابعينا الى بانوراما هذا
المساء نخصصها لمتابعه تطورات قضيه ترامب
في انتظار يوم المحاكمه يوم غد في اجزاء
وفي ملفات عده وهذه العناوين
بعدها اقل من 24 ساعه امريكا على موعد مع
محاكمه رئيس سابق ماذا ستقدم نيويورك
للتراب الادانه ام البراءه
محمد ترامب يواجهون الاضطهاد السياسي كما
يقولون بالاستعداد للمعركه هل سينجحون في
انقاذه واخراجه من القضيه باقل الخسائر
وفي نفس هذا الاطار ومع بدء محاكمته ترامب
الحالمي بالعوده للبيض الابيض ما هي حبوبه
الانتخابيه وهل ستمهد المحاكمه الطريق
امامه لولايه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل نيويورك المدينه
التي لا تنام لن تنام الليله هي على موعد
مع محاكمه اول رئيس امريكي متهما بارتكاب
جريمه وسط انقسام عميق وغير مسبوق في
الولايات المتحده دونالد ترامبث امام
محكمه منهاتنا الثلاثاء للاستماع لتهمم
الجنائيه الموجهه له من المتوقع ان يصل
الرئيس الامريكي السابق الى نيويورك وان
يهبط في مطار لاغوارديا في وقت لاحقنا
اليوم قادما من فلوريدا ثم سيتوجه الى
منزله في بورشيترام كما من المتوقع ان
يتواجد ترامب في مكتب المدعي العام لمنطقه
منهاتن البنراج من بعد ظهر الثلاثاء ثم
العوده الى فوريدا بعد جلسه محاكمته حيث
سيخاطب انصاره اما عن مدينه نيويورك فهي
تعيش حاله استنفار تام وتاهب يزداد مع كل
ساعه تمر لتقربنا من موعد المحاكمه منذ
ايام رجال شرطه في المدينه يعملون مدار
الساعه وينتشرون في كل مكان قرب مبنى
المحكمه وخارج برج ترامب في الجده الخامسه
كما لوحظ حضور ساحق من وسائل الاعلام
لتغطيه المحاكمه وما ستنتهي عليه وسط
توقعات باحتجاجات واحتفالات من انصار
ترامب او من خصومه فهل ستخدم مدينه
نيويورك المتهمه ام ستهديه حريه وشعبيه
اكبر
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع سنبدا بزمينا من
نيويورك بورس العربيه طلال الحاج اهلا بك
من واشنطن الدكتور ادمان غريب استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه من القاهره الدكتور طارق
فهمي الاستاذ والعلاقات الدوليه في
الجامعات الامريكيه ومن جده الدكتور بندر
دوشي الباحث في الامريكي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام قبل مناقشه هذه التطورات وفهم ما
المنتظر من يوم غد خاصه اسمحوا لي ان اقف
على اخر التطورات مع زميلنا طلال الحاج
طلال اهلا بك معنا حديث عن حضور امني مكثف
ومتابعه لكل مجريات هذا الحدث امنيا
وجماهيريا كيف هي الصوره
بالفعل الرئيس السابق
رحل من في طريقه الى نيويورك ونتوقع وصوله
الساعه تقريبا التاسعه عشر بتوقيت جرينتش
الى مطار الاغوار هنا في مدينه نيويورك
على متن طائره الخاصه وسيذهب فورا الى
منزله في نيويورك في مبنى ترامب تاور في
الجده الخامسه كما تفضلتي وسيتوجه صباح
الى مقر محكمه من هات الجنائيه التي
صورتي ورائي هنا في الصوره
وتضم المحاكم الجنائيه والمحاكم العليا
للولايه وسيصل هنا نحو الساعه السادسه عشر
بتوقيت جرينتش
من باب جانبي لن نراه ولن نستطيع تصويره
لانه
يختفي عنه الخلفيه وسيصعد الى الطابق
الخامس عشر وهو الطابق الوحيد الذي سيعمل
غدا في هذه المحكمه محكمه جميع حاكمها
قاعاتها مقفوله
والقضيه الوحيده التي تنظر فيها هي قضيه
ترامب هناك في الطابق 15 ستتم اخذ صوره
بصماته وربما حتى صوره ولكن اعتقد مكبل
هذه في واقع الامر ليست بدايه المحكمه هذه
فقط قراءه التهم الموجهه للمتهم بحضور
طبعا محاميه
وتسمى باللغه الانجليزيه
وبعد ذلك استراحه طبعا هو شخص شهير والديه
المال الكافي لاطلاق السراح وستوجه الى
على الفور الى عائدا الى
حيث سيلقي خطابا الساعه الرابعه والربع
بتوقيت دبي صباحا الغد صباح الاربعاء
هنا في هذه المحكمه
المخاطعه لان الصوت هناك تشويش على مستوى
الصوت اعذرني
ربما في مواعيد قادمه ونشرات قادمه اكيد
باننا سنبقى مع اكثر تفاصيل فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع طلال الحاج من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا
لك
ونناقش هذا التفصيل او هذه التطورات مع
ضيوفنا
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع الدكتور رائد دكتور
استمعت الى زمينه طلال الحاج تحدث عن حضور
امني وعن متابعه اعلاميه كذلك سواء في
بانوراما اليوم او في الايام السابقه كانت
هناك حشود في انتظار هذا اليوم في انتظار
يوم غد كل هذه الاجواء المشحونه تنبئ
بماذا
بالواضحه ان الولايات المتحده فعلا تمر
بمرحله صعبه جدا وان الرئيس ترامب الرئيس
السابق
لا يزال يهيمن وهذه القضيه قضيته امام
المحكمه تهيمن على افكار الامريكيين والى
حد ما على الافكار الكثير من المناطق في
العالم دول العالم
وهذه نقطه مثيره خاصه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الولايات المتحده هذه الايام
تواجه ارتفاع في الجريمه تواجد تضخم مالي
كبير نرى انهيار
لبنوك مهمه ان نرى في نفس تدفق المهاجرين
غير الشرعيين الى الولايات المتحده نرى
بان
الصراع الهويات لا يزال مستمر نرى ان
الولايات المتحده تواجه حرب في اوكرانيا
وحرب ربما احتمالات حرب اخرى قدراها في
تايوان ولكن التركيز الان خلال الايام
الماضيه في خاصه الثلاثه او الاربعه
الماضيه تقريبا وكان الخبر الوحيد او
الخبر الاول هو قضيه الرئيس السابق ترامب
واعتقد انه طبعا لها ما يبررها ولكن الى
حد ما وذلك لان هذه هي اول مره نرى فيها
محاكمه رئيس امريكي او توجيه تهم للرئيس
الامريكي وتم محاكمته بعد ذلك ايضا هذه هي
المره الاولى التي نرى فيها مثل هذا
الانقسام الحاد في المجتمع الامريكي
وهناك الكثيرين الذين يروا في بترامب على
انه يشكل خطر على الديمقراطيه يهدد
الدستور الامريكي بانه هو وراء الانقسامات
في الولايات المتحده بينما نرى اخرون ينظر
اليه على انه هو ضحيه هو على بالرغم من
انه رجل مشاكس وله شخصيته وعقليته الخاصه
الا انه هو دافع عن الولايات المتحده او
مصالح الولايات المتحده لم يدخل الولايات
المتحده في اي حروب وبالتالي فان هذه طبعا
كلها تظهر الى اي مدى نرى هذا الانقسام
عميق تحدث عنه مراقبون اكدته الان بحسب
قراءتك دكتور
ناتي لمناقشته بعد قليل ولكن العنوان
الرئيسي هو محاكمات ترامب وهذا ما يعيشه
داخل الامريكي وهنا السؤال دكتور بندر
امين عام الحزب الجمهوري مايكل ستيل يقول
في اخر تصريحاته على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تشد الاحزمه هل تعتقد بان
هذا التصحيح دقيق او انه مبالغ فيه
ان هناك نوع من البسامه ما يحدث الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو امر خطير
كما
الغريب ان القضيه هي
وجود
نوع من الاشكالات الداخليه الكبرى مثل
ازمه الحدود الصراع مع الصين الصراع مع
روسيا واوكرانيا
انهيار البنوك الداخلي اعتقد انه ما يح
عن الازمات الكبرى امريكا الان تواجه
منعطفات تاريخيه هناك وارتفاع في اسعار
النفط حاليا هناك الصين بدات تتعامل مع
دول اخرى كبرى بعمله اليوان وبالتالي يرى
خبراء استراتيجيون في الحزب الجمهوري انما
يحدث للرئيس الامريكي هو عمليه الهاء عن
الاحداث تضرب ان التقط منك هذا التوصيف
وهذه القراءه وانقلها لضيفي دكتور طارق هل
تعتقد او هل تتفق مع الدكتور بندر على ان
كل ما يحدث من تطورات من حضور امن مكثف من
حضور شعبي من متابعه من تصريحات هو الهاء
للقضايا الحقيقيه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ام ان هذه القضيه تستحق كل هذه
المتابعه
يعني انا في تقديري الشخصي لا تستحق كل
هذه الامور والاستعدادات الامنيه الغير
مسبوقه وكان امريكا كلها مستنفره بصوره
ربما مبالغ فيها بعض الشيء من عاش في
امريكا يعرف ان مثل هذه الامور تتم في
سياقات معينه وحادث الاقتحام الكونجرس
انتهى ولن يعود وبالتالي اعتقد حاله
المبالغه وراءها اسباب اخرى وهو محاوله
لنقل رساله بان الدوله الامريكيه
الامريكيه قويه وانها قادره على الرضع
وانها تتعامل بهذا المنطق هذا امر مبالغ
فيه الاجهزه الامنيه والاجهزه الفيدراليه
لديها كل المعلومات عن ما يمكن ان يحدث
وبالتالي التخوف من ان تحدث اعمال غير
مسبوقه او حشود او ان التيار الشعبوي
الفوضوي اليمين المتطرف ان يقوم باعمال
وغيرها هذا يعني هذه الامور مبالغه فيها
للغايه وبالتالي يواجه الرئيس الامريكي
معضله حقيقيه الان هناك استقطاب كبير في
الامه الامريكيه وفي الولايات المتحده على
مختلف درجاته هذا الاستقطابا اعتقد سيدفع
ثمن الجمهور الامريكي من الطرفين وليس
الطرف على حساب طرف اخر لكن اداره ملف
التحقيقات مع الرئيس ترامبا تثير علامات
استفهام كثيره حول اولا التاخير في توجيه
الاتهامات تنوع هذه الاتهامات ادله
الاتهامات عديده يعني لا تقتصر على 30
التام ربما تزيد او تقل في اكثر من ولايه
في اكثر من التحقيقات جاريه كلها علامات
استفهام حول الهدف منه هل هو الاطاحه
بالترامب من الواجهه ام هو هذا الصراع
والاستقطاب يجب ان ينتهي مع تياره في جمله
من التساؤلات تتجاوز ما يجري الان في اطار
محاكمه الرئيس ترامب ان كانت هناك مبالغه
ام لا ولكن هناك على الاقل نتفق بان هناك
امر واقع فدخل الامريكي ومتابعه كذلك من
مختلف المعنيين بهذه التطورات هذه
التطورات ستقسم او قسمت كما تفضل بالاشاره
الدكتور عثمان منذ قليل قسمت الدخل
الامريكي ولكن حتى قسمت الجمهوريين وهذا
سيكون محل نقاش بعد قليل ولكن اسمحوا
لضيوفي الكرام ان نتوقف مع هذا الفاصل من
بعد سنعود الى مناقشه كل هذه الملفات
اذا مشاهدينا الى فاصل من بعد سنعود
لنتابع
محامي ترامب يواجهون لاضطهاد السياسي كما
يقولون بالاستعداد للمعركه هل سينجحون في
انقاذ ترامب واخراجه من القضيه باقل
الخسائر
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد وزير العدل في عهد رئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب نصح الاخير
بالا يتولد دفاع عن نفسه بنفسه ويرى
الوزير هذه الفكره سيئه جدا لترامب لانه
يفتقر لضبط نفسك كما قال ربما قد يسبب ذلك
ازعاجا لفريق الدفاع ولكن ثمه ما يزعج
ايضا محامي تراب نجد بتصويت هيئه محلفين
لصالح توجيه الاتهام لموكلهم واصفين الامر
بانه اضطهاد سياسي وهو ذات الوصف الذي
استخدمه ترامب قبل ايام اجرائيا لا يتوقع
محامي ترامبرجو تاكوبينا ان يبادر الدفاع
الى طلب رد القضيه فورا مشيرا الى انه كلا
رئيس السابق لن يتسنى لهم بعد الاطلاع على
التهم غير ان المحامي جيمس تراستي توقع
ثغرات قانونيه ستشوب هذا الاتهام تقيم
القضيه ضد ترامب صعب حاليا فلا تهمه دقيقه
ولا ادله واضحه على الاقل حتى هذه الساعه
وتم التامه قد يشكل عثرات امام سعلت دعاء
لاصدار حكم بالادانه مثلا شهادات وادله
محل تساؤلات فالشاهد
محامي سابق مدان قانون التقادم كذلك في
نيويورك خمس سنوات فقط والقضيه تاريخها
منذ 2016 اي مر عليها اكثر من خمس سنوات
فريق الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ربما يطلب نقل القضيه الى دائره اخرى
الفريق يخشى ان لا ينال ترامب محاكمه
عادله في منهج
بالاتهامات واعتبرها اضطهادا سياسيا ليس
هدف حسب ترامب ذهب الى ما هو ابعد
زعم ان القاضي المكلف بالنظر في القضيه
يكرهه
ولهذا اختاره المدعي العام لمنحه
نعود من جديد الى مناقشه هذا الموضوع وهذه
التطورات اسمحوا لي ان ابدا معك دكتور في
الواقع اختلفت تصنيفات ما يحدث من تطورات
بين القائل بان ما يحدث هو محاكمه قانونيه
او قضيه قانونيه البعض يصفها بالسياسيه
البعض الاخر ذهب حتى لتوصيفها بالشخصيه
ولكن مهما يكن التوصيف هل تعتقد بحسب
قراءتك بان ترامب قادر على ان يستفيد من
هكذا تطورات او انها ستضر به سيتضرر من
هذا الملف
فعلا هذا السؤال الرئيسي هذا السؤال المهم
لانه هناك من يعتقد اولا ان الديمقراطيين
فعلا بتركيزهم على ترامب يريدون اقصائه
هناك هذا الراي الذي يقول بانهم لا يريدوا
ابعاد ترامب ومنعه من ترشيح نفسه او اذا
بعد الاتهامات حتى ولو لم تتم اذانته علما
بان المحاكمه قد تستمر حتى ربما حتى
الحمله الانتخابيه في 2024
وبالتالي فان كل هذه الامور تثير اسئله
الاعتقاد البعض بان ترامب بان
الديمقراطيين يعتقدوا بان ترامب هو رجل
خطر هو رجل يهدد
اي مرشح ديمقراطي وبالتالي فان
فانه يجب على الاقل توجيه ضربات له
التوجيه اتهامات له لانه عند اذا ربما قد
نرى اداه كبير من الامريكيين الذين يعيدوا
النظر خاصه بين
الاشخاص الذين يناصرونه او المستقلين على
الاقل
كذلك يا دكتور لان الضربه التي لا تقتلك
فهي تقويك وترام شهد في ما قبل يعني
بعض القضايا التي خرج منها فائزا وهنا
سؤال دكتور بندر هل تعتقد بان ترامب قادر
على مواجهه هذه القضيه رغم انها سابقه في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
لم ترفع اصلا ضده هناك
تركيز ديمقراطي على الرئيس الامريكي لا
ننسى ان الرئيس السابق استطاع ان يجذب 75
مليون صوت من عام 2020 خسر الانتخابات
بعشرات الالاف في بعض الولايات وبالتالي
اعتقد ان المشكله الرئيس الامريكي دون
التراب هو استقطابي بحاد وان القضايا
الموجهه ضده انا اعتقد انها لا تؤثر عليه
بقدر ما انها تساعده على البروز وعلى
اظهار الشخصيات ولكن
قضيه اخرى ايضا هو ترامب نفسه يحب الاضواء
يستطيع ان يتعامل مع الاضواء يستطيع ان
يتعامل مع الجماهير
البعض بان هذه الاضواء قد تكون اضواء تحرق
وليست اضواء يمكن ان تنفع يعني حضرتك لما
تقول بان ترامب يحب الظهور ويحب استغلال
مثل هكذا مواقف ولكن في النهايه هذه
المواقف قادره على الاضرار به
نعم السؤال هو هل يستطيع ترم استماله
المستقلين والمعتدلين من من الجمهورين هنا
السؤال اعتقد ان ترامب فشل في عام 2020 في
استقطاب المستقلين والجمهورين عام 2020
والسؤال هنا هل عام 2024 هل يستطيع ترامب
ان يستقدم هذه الفئه المهمه المرجحه للفوز
بالرئاسه انا اشك في ذلك ولكن الديمقراطي
يرون ان توجيه الاتهامات للرئيس الامريكي
للرئيس ربما
سيعطي اثاره لدى القاعده الجماهيريه التي
يحضنها المعتدرين في الحزب الجمهوري يرون
هناك جزء كبير اعتقد 12% و16% من
الجمهوريه المعتدليه يرون ان الاتهام هو
اتهام حقيقي وان يجب الرئيس الامريكي ان
يواجه المحاكمه
المستقلون يرون 48% من المستقلين يعتقدون
ان الالتهاب دوافع سياسي وبالتالي التركيز
الان هو على المستقلين والمعتدلين في
الحزب الجمهوري وتقرير ما اذا كانوا
سيرجحون كفه ترامب او المرشحه الديمقراطي
ايضا هناك نقطه اخرى مهمه الجهه
الديمقراطيه الاخرى هناك اشكاليه في
المرشحين بايدن لم يعلن الترشح مجموعه
اغلبيه الديمقراطيين لا يريدون بايدن
يترشح
وبالتالي هناك اشكاليه ايضا كبيره في
الجهه المقابله يرى انه اذا واجه
بهذا السن وبهذا العمر وبهذه الكوارث
الازمات الداخليه يستطيع ان يهزمها ولكن
هناك ازمه ليس فقط الديمقراطين هناك ازمه
كذلك لدى الجمهوريين يقول البعض وسناتي
على هذه النقطه ولكن في مرحله متقدمه من
هذه الحلقه ولكن دكتور طارق
مع كل هذه التطورات الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب استخدم لعبه الشارع وحضرتك كما قلنا
تبعنا تصريحاته منذ البدايه كان يحاول
اللعب على هذه النقطه ونجح فيها ولكنها
ورطتها في احداث الكونجرس هل تعتقد بان
هذه التصريحات ستكلفها يوم غد
لا اعتقد يعني الرجل بارع في التعامل مع
الميديا ومع الساحه السياسيه الحزبيه داخل
حزب وخارجه هو يبني مظلوميه جيده الان هذه
المظلوميه بصرف النظر عن توجيه الاتهامات
بصوره مباشره وهذا الامر سياخذ عده اشهر
ربما يعني ستطول موضوع المحاكمات وانضمام
بعضا القضايا الاخرى وتفنيد الادله
والاتهامات الموجهه له وبالتالي الرجل
يذهب الى المحاكمه وهو يدرك جيدا ان الامر
لن يحسم خلال فتره وجيزه وبالتالي هو يرتب
حملته الانتخابيه ويفكر وفق نفسك والعقيد
الفكري ان يتعامل مع المشهد الانتخابي على
طريق التكتيكي والاستراتيجي معا وبالتالي
اعتقد انه حتى الان هو يربح من مما يجري
بصرف النظر على انه لديه الامكانيات
والقدرات في التعامل مع الميديا والسوشيال
ميديا يعني هذه الامور تفهم في سياقها
اعتقد انه يعني يريد ان يخرج من حاله
الفشل التي دخلها في الانتخابات التجديد
النصفي للكونجرس كما تعلمي وكانه وقتها
يدير الانتخابات من ليست انتخابات
انما انتخابات خاصه بالرئاسه وبالتالي حزب
الجمهوري عينه ايضا عليه بصوره او باخرى
الرجل يتعامل مع منطق مختلف تماما عكس ما
هو كان في الرئاسه بطبيعه الحال هو يواجه
اكثر من معركه من داخل حزبه ومن خارجه
ومساحه السياسيه لكن القاعده الرئيسه التي
يتحرك من خلالها هي قاعده اليمين
المتطرف هي القاعده الشعبويه التي تتهم
بانها فوضويه يستطيع ان يحرك الشارع له
انصاره له جمهور المؤيد محاوله استقطابه
لهم يعني ارضيه اخرى للشرائح داخل لحزب
الجمهوري او على المستوى الفيدرالي اعتقد
صعبه للغايه لان هذه قواعد ثابته تاخذ
فتره طويله انت تعلمي ان هذه الامور بتاخذ
بعض الوقت واستطلاعات الراي الصحيحه انها
تؤيده الان من داخل الحزب الجمهوري وتؤيد
ترشيحه لكن هذه خريطه يعني عائمه بمعنى
انها لا يمكن ان تحسميها بصوره اخرى في
سلم وجود منافسين اقوياء للغايه داخل حزب
الجمهوري والحزب ليست ترامب كما تصور
البعض هناك مرشحين يعني يتمتعون بمزايا
كثيره ويستطيعون ان يدخلوا معركه كبيره
لكن نحن نتحدث الان ليس خلال الفتره
المقبله ان نتحدث عن ارضيه الواقع اعتقد
ان ترامب ليس ضعيفا بل هو قويا يستطيع ان
يقدم مقاربه جديده ومختلفه وسيستطيع ان
يفلت من كل هذه الاتهامات على الاقل لبناء
مظلوميه جماهيريه في هذا التوقيت طالما
تحدثت دكتور طارق عن استطلاعات الراي هناك
استطلاع للراي واود قراءتك لو سمحت دكتور
لنفهم كيف يفكر الشارع الامريكي يعني اي
بي سي قامت باستطلاع
وكشفت بان 51 بالمئه يطالبون بادانه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب فيما يخص
الشتياح الكونجرس اقل من هذه النسبه
وبالتحديد 45% يطالبون بادانته في هذه
الدعوه الحاليه بما يفسر ذلك
اولا اعتقد ان ما نراه الان فيما يتعلق
مثلا بموضوع الدعم الاطراء بدون شك الراي
العام ايضا اجمالا مقسم
وهناك اسئله ايضا حول بعض الاستطلاعات لان
الاسئله التي توجه
للمستطلعين
قد تؤدي او تؤثر على الاجابه ولذلك لا
اعتقد وانا على الاقل شخصيا لا اعطي
الكثير من الاهتمام لهذه المستطاعات في
هذه المرحه
ربما قد نرى تغيير في المستقبل خاصه بعد
ان نرى ما هي التهم نرى كيف سيرد محاض
ترامب نراعي الى اي مدى مثلا قد يستمر
التحقيق ليس فقط مع الرئيس السابق بل كيف
سيتم التحقيق ايضا مع المدعي العام لان
هناك عده ثلاث لجنات الان في مجلس النواب
من الجمهور الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوري
يطالب
بتحقيق مع
وهو المدعي العام لانهم يقولوا انه مسيس
او انه يسيس هذه الاتهامات ضد الرئيس انه
يحاول استخدام
المبررات قانونيه غير لا يمكن تبريرها
وبالتالي فان هذا يظهر بان الراي العام
نفسه منقسم ايضا راينا ان غالبيه القيادات
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب حتى البعض
والقيادات التي تامل بترشيح نفسها في
الانتخابات القادمه قامت بدعم ترامب وعدم
في الجزء القادم دكتور ادمان سنتحدث لان
التاثيرات قادره ان تكون مثيره وكثيره
كذلك على الوجه الانتخابي الامريكي
والانتخابات التمهيديه 2024 المنتظره ولكن
بعد فاصل قصير اعود لضيوفي واعود
لمتابعينا بهذا العنوان
اذا فاصل من بعده نعود لنتابع
مع بدء محاكم بالحليمه بالعوده الى البيت
الابيض ما هي حظوظه الانتخابيه وهل ستمهد
المحاكمه الطريق امامه لولايه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد محاكمه ومفاجات وسنريوهات
واتهامات الى ان رئيس الامريكيه السابق
دونالد ترامب يكتسح استطلاعات الراي داخل
الحزب الجمهوري بحسب استطلاع لراي اجرته
شركه يوغوف اكثر من خمسين بالمئه من
الجمهوريين مستعدون لدعم ترشيح ترامب خلال
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله المزمعي
عقدها عام 2024
ورغمانيه السلطات الامريكيه توجيه اتهامات
ضد ترامب الا ان غالبيه الجمهوريين
مستعدون لدعم ترامب وفقا للاستطلاع الذي
اظهر ايضا انه من بين جميع المرشحين عن
الحزب الجمهوري في الانتخابات التنفيذيه
يمكن ان يصوت 52% من مؤيدي الحزب لصالح
ترامب يليه حاكم
ثم الحاكم او الحاكم السابقه لولايه سافكا
رولاينا في المركز الثالث ثم يدخل السباق
منافس جمهوري اخر لترامب نتحدث عن حاكم
ولايه تركنس س السابق اسا هاتشنسون الذي
يريد الترشح الانتخابات رئاسه الامريكيه
لعام 24 تراب الان يواجه المحكمه ولكن
عينه مفتوحه على قاعدته الانتخابيه لا بل
يجمع التوافق لوقف القضيه ويطلب التبرعات
ايضا
[موسيقى]
اعود مجدد الى ضيوفي وتحديد معك دكتور
بندر دكتور بندر قبل الدخول في تفاصيل
الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري بشكل عام هل
تعتقد بان الضوابط الديمقراطيه بان الاطر
القانونيه التي عرفت بها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او على الاقل هي التي تروج لهذه
الصوره هل تعتقد بانها قادره ان تصمت مع
هكذا ملف او ان شوائب السياسه قد تؤثر
اعتقد ان الاتهام السياسي موجهه وانا اصفه
بالوجه للرئيس الامريكي
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رغم ان
هناك حديث من قبل الديموقراطين بانه لا
احد فوق القانون ولكن اذا عملنا مقارنه
بسيطه بين قضيه دون ترامب الحاليه التي
ارتكبها قبل توليه الرئاسه وبين قضيه التي
ارتكبها اثول ان هناك معايير مزدوجه بين
الجانبين على اي
حال الديمقراطيه الامريكيه ديمقراطيه قويه
متشعبه هناك
وبالتالي هناك مقوله من يدير المجلس
النواب ولجان التحقيق هو من صاحب الحزب او
صاحب الحظوظ الاوفر حظا للانتصار في
الانتخابات التاليه وبالتالي اعتقد تتحدث
في كل الحالات عن ازدواجيه في المعايير عن
الكيل بمكيالين وهنا سؤال دكتور اضمام هل
هناك تعامل
مزدوج بين ما عمل به بالكلينتون وما يعامل
به ترامب اليوم
بدون شك هناك تعامل مزدوج ذلك نرى ان
الرئيس
مثلا
بعد التوجيه الاتهامات له والتحقيق معه
وقلنا لم تتم اذا ولم يحاكم
وفي نفس الوقت راينا ايضا انه هو حقق
انتصارات او فوز اكبر في الانتخابات
النصفيه بعد تلك الحارثان مما حقق قبلها
وبالتالي فان هذا مختلف ايضا ان المدعي
العام في في ولايه نيويورك الذي يقوم
بتوجيه الاتهامات الان للرئيس السابق
استهدف الرئيس وقال انه عندما قام بحملته
الانتخابيه قال انه سيستهدف ترامب
وسيلاحقه
وساحاول ادانته ومحاكمته وبالتالي فان هذا
يظهر بانه هو كان له موقف وهو يهاجم ايضا
بان مدينه نيويورك ارتفعت فيها الجريمه
بنسبه 300% ان كانت عمليات القتل عمليات
الاقتصاد عمليات السرقه او عمليات كل يعني
الاعمال الاجراميه
فانه هو
50% من هذه الحوادث لم يلاحقها ولم
يتابعها لا بل انه تعامل معها بطريقه لبعض
الاشخاص المجرمين الذين قاموا بعمليات
القتل تم الافراج عنهم ثم قاموا بعد ذلك
تقول بانه ترامب هو المقصود او هو
المستهدف يعني نحن نخرج من اطار التنافس
الحزبي بين حزبين الى شخصنه الموضوع
الدكتور طارق هل الموضوع تخطى المعركه
التقليديه الحزبيه الى معركه شخصيه تستهدف
ترامب الاساس خاصه وان الاصوات التي اتت
ضد ترامب اتت كذلك من داخل الحزب الجمهوري
بالتاكيد طبعا هناك شخصنه واضحه في على كل
المستويات سواء كان في التوجيه ادله
الاتهامات او في بعض المحاميين حتى الذين
دخلوا وخرجوا وجهت لهم اتهامات وبالتالي
الموضوع قائم على فكره المعايير المزدوجه
والتعامل مع
المحاكمات بهذه الصوره بل واستهداف الرئيس
ترامب الرئيس الامريكي السابق كما تعلمي
محل يعني تحافظات كثيره داخل الولايات
المتحده ودخل الامه الامريكيه وداخل
المؤسسات الدوله العميقه الكبرى التي تنظر
الى ترامب ليس كرئيس وانما هو معبر عن
طيار يعني شعبوي وفوضوي وهذا الامر يا مس
سمعه الولايات المتحده لانه كما تجري
المحاكمات هناك تاثيرات في اوضاع سوق
المال والاقتصاديات وبالتالي هناك حاله من
الارتباك خلال الساعات الاخيره ايضا
مرتبطه باستمرار هذه المحاكمات في
ارتدادات عكسيه وسلبيه ستمثل الولايات
المتحده وتمس النموذج الامريكي نفسه في
موضوع الديمقراطيه والليبراليه والتعدديه
هذه امور طبعا محكومه ومنضبطه الولايات
المتحده هي نموذج لهذا الاطار وتتوقع ذلك
تتوقع بان هذا الملف قد يمس من الاطار
الديمقراطي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بالتاكيد طبعا لانه هذا النموذج الكبير
والولايات المتحده بتقدمه للعالم منذ
اقتحام الكونجرس والمساس بفكره الليبراليه
والتعدديه والنمط الديمقراطي في النظام
السياسي الفيدرالي الامريكي ثم الان حديث
حضرتك حول هل هناك ابعاد شخصيه في ما يجري
بطبيعه الحال هناك تصريحات مع وضد الرئيس
الامريكي السابقا هناك شخصنه واضحه فيما
سيجري كل هذه الامور تضع علامات استفهام
حقيقيه حول جدي ومجاهد
وطبعاكمات على المقاطعه الاسئله كثيره
والوقت قليل دكتور بندر ضيفي يا دكتور
طارق يتحدث عنه الشخصان البعض سيقول بانه
ان كانت هناك شخصا لهذه القضيه من الخارج
فهذا يمكن ان يكون مفهوم ولكن من داخل حزب
الجمهوري ونحن نعلم بان هناك اصوات تعالت
لتقف ضد ترامب بما يفسر ذلك
لا يريدون الترشح الرئيس الامريكي دون
الكرام على راسهم الاغلبيه الاقليه
الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ هناك من يرى ان
الرئيس الامريكي دون ترامب فشل في انتزاع
اغلبيه مجلس النواب 2018 وفشلت الانتخابات
الراسي عام 2020 وفشل في انتخابات عام
2022 وبالتالي اخذ الفرصه الكامله
هو الان الشعار لهذا الفصيل وبالتالي هو
فصيل قوي فصيل قوي واعتقد ان يرون انه من
الافضل والايدى البحث عن شخصيه اخرى ولذلك
نلاحظ ان فقط خمسه من اعضاء الكونجرس
الجمهور هم من ايد وترام لكن حاليا
ترامبول قوي وشخصيه السياسيه المهيمنه على
الحزب الجمهوري لا اعتقد من الحزب
الجمهوري يستطيع الترشح بدون موافقه ترامب
او استطيع الفوز بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
بدون اقرار وموافقه رن على ترشح وبالتالي
اعتقد ان ترامب
يسبب او يخلق مشكله معضله حزب الجمهوري
وامام
الناخبين الجمهوري هناك نوع من الارتباك
داخل الحزب الجمهوري الحالي استهداف الذي
توجه الذي وجه الرئيس الامريكي دون ترامب
هو استهداف ضد الحزب الجمهوري خلق نوع من
الارتباك لا يعرف المرشحون اين يتجهون هل
يدعمون ترامب وفي هذا الاطار البعض يطرح
اسماء اخرى وهنا سؤال دكتور اضمان
هل تعتقد بانه سيكون الامثل
المختار من حزب الجمهوريين خاصه وان البعض
يصفه بالمعتدل المتوازن ام ان صوره ترامب
تبقى حاضره وقويه داخل الحزب اعتقد انها
الدعم في اوساط الجمهوريين حتى ان بعض
استطلاعات الراي فقط لا تمنحه الا حوالي
بعض اثنان بالمئه قال احد الاستطلاعات
الاخرى قال ثلاثه بالمئه وهنا اعتقد ان
النقطه المهمه التي ننساها هي ان الغالبيه
الجمه يقفوا مع ترامب بعضهم لانهم يحبونه
لانهم يعتقدوا انه هو فعلا الرجل الافضل
لقياده الولايات المتحده والاخرين لانهم
يعلموا ان لديه قاعده شعبيه عريضه تدعمه
وبالتالي لذلك راينا
يدعم ترامب راينا ايضا حيلي التي هاجمته
قبل ذلك تدعم ترامب وتتهم المعارضيه
وعزيز لانه كل هذا قد يتغير مع التهم
الدقيقه ومع بدء هذه المحاكمه لا نعلم
سنبقى في متابعه كل ذلك اود شكركم جزيل
الشكر بما ان الحلقه انتهت اليوم من
واشنطن غريب من القاهره الدكتور طارق فهمي
ومن جد الدكتور بدار دوشي شكرا جزيلا لكم
السلام عليكم